bathroom yeah is that where you close it
yeah yeah yeah all right his back
favorite moment
what's that for private moments they
have talks to do things yeah that's
where you go
that's jennifer lopez revealing where
she and ben affleck sneak off for some
alone time i have nothing to complain
about on wednesday the 52-year-old
triple threat stopped by the ellen
degeneres show and opened up about how
she and her man escape for some quick
alone time from the five children they
have between them
bathroom yeah is that where you go
that's it yeah yeah yeah all right his
back favorite moment
what's up for private moments to have
talks to do things yeah that's where you
go
to the bathroom yeah of course jen
shares 13 year old twins max and emmy
with her ex mark anthony while ben and
his ex jennifer garner are parents to 16
year old violet 13 year old seraphina
and nine-year-old samuel the actress and
the oscar winner rekindled their romance
last year 17 years after calling off
their engagement we were about to get
married it didn't work out and it was
just a bad heartbreak it was like a
tough one for me and while jen didn't
say a whole lot about their reignited
love on ellen she did say this
i don't think anybody was more surprised
than us yeah
no but it is no seriously though i mean
that's just would you ever have imagined
that it comes full circle it ends up no
you you never could imagine something
like that could happen it's a beautiful
thing
on tuesday the lovebirds stepped out at
the la premiere of jen's latest flake
marry me and didn't shy away from a
little red carpet pda
you were standing taking photos in front
of a sign that says marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big is
i've heard you say so many times that
you are a hopeless romantic and you
still believe in love you believe in
marriage so like cat you still believe
in all of those absolutely why wouldn't
i has been seen the movie yet you
brought your fella with you tonight he's
seen it yeah yeah this is just a good
date night it's a great date night we're
super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just having a
good time and all that comes after jlo
reflected on their past relationship
with rolling stone
saying that it was one of the happiest
times in her life but all that public
hate really got to them quote it really
destroyed our relationship from the
inside out because we were just too
young to understand at that time what
were really the most important things in
life it was my first kind of heartbreak
i mean i had like a puppy love
heartbreak when i was like 12.
you know what i mean but no i don't
really count that one it was my first
like adult heartbreak was it because it
was so public and we wanted to know
every single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help but jen says this time
around we shouldn't expect a breakup
it's just a dream come true quote we
feel like what we found again is so much
more important and how we protect that
and how we live our lives what to share
what not to share is the balance that we
have now the benefit of experience and
the wisdom that we gained over the years
cheers to rekindled love and stealing
moments together however and wherever
you can is that where you go
yeah yeah yeah for private moments to
have talks to do things yeah that's
where you go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]